So there're important lessons in what we just learned,
the key thing is we talked about conditional probabilities.
We said that the outcome in a variable, like a test
is actually not like the random coin flip
but it depends on something else,
like a disease.
When we looked at this,
we were able to predict
what's the probability of a test outcome
even if we don't know whether the person has a disease or not.
And we did this using the truth table,
and in the truth table,
we summarized multiple lines.
For example, we multiplied the probability of a test outcome
condition on this unknown variable,
whether the person is diseased
multiplied by the probability of the disease being present.
Then we added a second row of the truth table,
where our unobserved disease variable
took the opposite value of not diseased.
Written this way, it looks really clumsy,
but that's effectively what we did when we went to the truth table.
So we now understand that certain coin flips
are dependent on other coin flips,
so if god, for example, flips the coin of us having a disease or not,
then the medical test again
has a random outcome,
but its probability really depends on whether we have the disease or not.
We have to consider this when we do probabilistic inference.
In the next unit,
we're going to ask the real question.
Say we really care about whether we have a disease like cancer or not.
What do you think the probability is,
given that our doctor
just gave us a positive test result?
And I can tell you,
you will be in for a surprise.